what's going on there reject nation
thank you so much for clicking on this
video we are going to continue
peacemaker today monkey dory season one
episode five ah this show is awesome i
love this show if you guys can go ahead
and hit that like button that would be
so appreciated uh subscribe click that
notification bell to get notified when
our reaction for the next peacemaker is
up and while you're at it leave a
comment what you thought about this
episode helps the engagement yeah i
could really know that stuff as always
full-length watch longs where you sync
up with the time code for peacemaker
will be over at our patreon page
massive thank you to all it becomes
super jacks by joining us on the journey
over there i said that's weird lastly
the boys are prepper thank you guys so
much for helping us edit down these
highlights
slaves
let's get to it
this is the first intro to have a dour
tone to it
oh
[Music]
oh it's an affectionate son
it's very meaningful to me but no
i'm not going to eat it
you should out of respect
[Music]
she's probably co-named that [ __ ]
they enter the human body through one of
its orifices and borrow through the
brain where they're then in control of
the body they go through the butt
i think that's just some uh creativity
on the part of whomever did the
animation
superman's an alien he's got a poop
fetish what [ __ ] out of here oh yeah he
uberly mays the old schaizes i
understand it where do you get this
nonsense
the fluid seems to be the butterfly's
only food source this was on the
bulletin board in the gulf home leota
noticed that this is also where annie
sterphausen was employed
you [ __ ] suck at
powerpoint yeah
i didn't mean to put your father in
prison then why'd you put him there you
fat [ __ ] because i couldn't think of
anybody what about ariana grande or
drake what
khloe kardashian the red tiger from
voltron
montana joe montana eddie murphy michael
jordan michael b jordan bts eugene levy
danny devito
the raw amber fluid is potentially
processed and bottled at glantai
bottling company glantai is in little
cork about two hours northwest of here
so you all are gonna take a field trip
and see what you can find out road trip
is take my prints check and see if they
match those ones you found in the
apartment or if someone's gaming the
system cause i didn't [ __ ] do it then
who did moment of truth
my [ __ ] had [ __ ] son oh being a bully
is just part of his personality what
like how you used to call me brother
prince charming my brother was a
handsome man that was a compliment
i'm gonna go out on a limb here and say
that i don't think he considered it a
compliment that you called him prince
charming because his penis was shaped
like a scepter
caught me thimble
symbol
yeah i was a late bloomer i didn't go
through puberty until my mid-20s
but the other guys after chris came up
with a nickname for him usually based on
their penises they would just walk into
the other room and sob because that will
become their name for the rest of their
life why are you seeing their penises
it's locker room dude what am i going to
do look at a towel
[Laughter]
my friend vanie mcvanerstein said i was
like a gypsy but with dicks instead of
palms
hey i got bullied too
oh my kid's calling me a bully all the
time telling me i was abusive
you should make that like an online
marketing thing upload your dick and
then peacemaker will give it a nickname
perfect
we could always do a white snake
powerball what about some jazz yes try
to listen to vigilante's quiet farts
back there than jazz no i didn't
[Music]
what is that someone's acting out
[Laughter]
not peacemaker
you guys got any hanoi rocks up there
you
no handling rocks who's hanoi rocks only
the greatest band of all time they're
the original glam mentality started at
all so many streets in this country
named after martin luther king jr but
not a single hanoi bronx avenue
oh
street kids no it says 11th street kids
dude it's one of their best songs yeah i
saw him in finland when i was 14 during
a year abroad bonding
what a shame
we're here
you're a butterfly man you don't need
that gun
[Music]
who knocks on the window and there's a
door right there
exactly what i was thinking
oh well i said you needed my help
situation is delicate requires something
other than your usual sledgehammer on
these days murray i'm barely ball peen
i'll take care of you
okay recep fawns ben mendelsohn
no
no
[Music]
[ __ ] me
come on
they made us do it we were afraid for
our lives heaven you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes
oh [ __ ] i'm never ever gonna kill
someone with a [ __ ] chainsaw so not
fair still a couple episodes left man
vigilante you're with me we'll check the
bays around back peacemaker you and
autobio question the employees in the
front office find out
that's what they were
definitely gonna be chill [ __ ] chill
dude jesus relax
i'm freaking out
hey how you doing okay how are you oh
murder butterflies
what the [ __ ] x-ray vision i can see in
their brains
wow
great gag
you don't have to shoot people after
already killed
it's good practice
is this all they can eat
must be
wow
[Music]
damn it was like a zombie movie like
zack snyder's army of the dead
exactly
what the hell
whoa
there's a [ __ ]
oh it's the gorilla gorilla yeah
it's a gorilla garage says the one that
escaped from the zoo right yeah and the
news i think the episode's here what the
hell is that it's a grenade i tied to a
russian tank shot why not just the
grenade grenade blows up like two people
how many people does this blow up i
don't know i invented it this morning
what
oh no
peace [ __ ]
[Applause]
cool
you guys
you're gonna have to go in there i'm
worried he's gonna die run at abaya
would have been appreciated
oh really
i need to take a run from a [ __ ] bomb
that is a good point
it is a fallback he did tell you exactly
what it was
oh [ __ ] oh no
oh no
[ __ ]
that i think it is gorilla grodd just
told him to die
oh
i don't like seeing a girl uh i don't
know if it's girl grug
you [ __ ] stunned yeah haha
[ __ ]
stuck finally
hardcore
not bad huh
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's just told he's not getting out of
jail and got his fingerprint results
back from the lab they matched the
prince of the crime scene oh
no captain what the hell is going on
what
oh sh
you're good
let me take the rest of the night off
give yourself a well-deserved rest i
don't need a wrestler request detective
is that character actor chris heyerdahl
doesn't need to be pre-faced with
character actor
no
hello
it's done
good
this means butterflies can use any life
form as a host chihuahua
probably wouldn't fit would be cool
though that wouldn't be cool at all why
would that be cool you tell me
it wouldn't be there's your answer
i love him
you all of them the rest
i mean it would have been a lot cooler
for convos came in and he was like hey
and then he tossed me the chainsaw
across the room
and then i killed a gorilla you're
talking about me i had just said how
much i wanted to kill someone with a
chainsaw like 50 minutes earlier and
then economos just coincidentally comes
in and kills someone with one i mean it
kind of seems like he was trying to [ __ ]
with me a little [ __ ] thimble oh
hey sweetie hey uncle will
we need a search warrant you ever heard
of a guy named peacemaker
come on in i feel like everyone's a
butterfly yeah
that's a condemning photo
[Laughter]
i'm not gonna grab a drink what do you
mean come on i want to celebrate
uh
are you gonna try to [ __ ] me back
[Music]
i think i really broke my dick
ah
tight man damn
gotta see that at some point
oh my god oh
god
[Laughter]
what's rude is you give me a feces drink
no it's not that bad
yum
do you just have a beer
you in hardcore
hell chris i don't know
look i doubt that you and her are a
possibility but hey
you never know i'm quoting here
just because you're handsome
[Laughter]
it's not even a sentence
well um
she said uh no just because you're
handsome
you think you can do whatever you want
right even though you're a piece of [ __ ]
murderer
you really aren't a bad guy indeed chris
smith i think people actually might like
you i like you i just never had this
before
what
this you give me advice and having my
back
the diary
no
why are you here i couldn't sleep
oh the x-ray
no
activate x-ray vision
be cool
be cool
yo mr mirn this is crazy you gotta check
this
hug
oh
no no no no no
[Music]
do not harm her
damn
that is
gonna kill her off
the way they held that in the x-ray
vision makes it scarier pov
trying to guess where the post credit
scene would be from it's got to be more
names he's spouting off of who they
could have framed is my guess it's not
bad call yes go with it like that it was
just like a whole bunch of improv
i'm gonna say something with the cops
mariska hargitay mario super mario
[ __ ] luigi yoshi do all guys from the
balcony and the mukbangs jim morrison
any one of the [ __ ] beatles pete best
what's this most of those you're right
could probably go to prison but i would
never put ariana grande in there she
looks too innocent possibly true
possibly
this is such a delightful show
damn i forgot all about the planning of
the diary yeah man until like moments
where it happened they're good at making
you forget about the the heaviest things
true
well it seems like that secret with mirn
is about to come out in a really huge
way in the next episode yeah
because uh yeah i i was kind of taken
aback that like i can't remember how
many episodes this season is supposed to
be but one thing i do appreciate is
while i would imagine that if this is
super successful they want to continue
it does seem like they don't have to
pull any punches in terms of how the
story is moving and i feel like we're at
that sort of halfway point now or maybe
even a little past it
where yeah for mern's true nature to
start revealing itself i think is is you
know is the next sort of logical domino
to fall because yeah i mean we've had
these little teases of him having more
and more emotion and even in his small
appearance in this episode he seems to
be
emoting more and this you know being
that it is the cliffhanger and it's a
pretty vicious attack part of me
in any tv show when an episode ends like
this i'm like okay what's going to be
the reversal at the end of the next one
but right now i can't really imagine a
reversal so much as just you know the
repercussions of yeah her
accidentally discovering this really
nasty secret
uh but you know i mean it could work out
in some other way that mirn is actually
you know kind of going against his
people or whatever but i don't know i
thought that was a very sort of uh
intense way to cap things off after a
pretty
you know like straightforward mission
episode you know yep i mean definitely
especially because
what i think this show has been doing
really well is knowing how to handle
uh the downtime of these characters like
really that's when they really like
character development happen it's like
usually when they're talking about
missions it's either something that's
intense or funny like they keep it
really like comic based with a lot of
the banter and stuff but even within the
banter they keep a character base which
is something i really appreciate about
this show right that's like the
beginning of this with peacemaker and i
call him divert the peacemaker and
economist
with you know like all the
insulting that he he's directing towards
him is all things that he's like he
loved that way how they edited that
together where obviously john cena rift
a lot of pop culture celebrity names and
then when he like explodes on him about
like putting his dad back in jail you're
like yeah that's what this is all really
about he's always picked on him but now
it's like this aggressive form and i
like those the layers that they add to
it of he's a bully and he doesn't really
acknowledge or even realize just how
verbally abusive he can actually be even
like i love that line but like i've been
bullied too people call me a bully and
they you know they talk about how
abusive i am yeah
that makes me feel really bad such a
narcissistic way of handling things yeah
and i love that i love the way they
implement that into the series
but it's cool of you know they they set
them up here where yeah we're just six
people we're taking on the alien threat
we're taking on this world
and
yet by the time they're done with their
mission they conquer something
that normally anyone would die doing i
don't like animal deaths and stuff i can
handle watching them i personally just
don't
remember like on board to see it
especially killing a gorilla not my cup
of tea
but it was still an exciting scene and
it is just so funny how like you don't
see that coming that's what i think is
great about how they handle the arc of
them coming together as a unit that's
something that we've talked about in
earlier episodes is like when's that
moment gonna be
this is like the james gunn show
misfits you know or have to band
together in ways they don't want to so
you know what's gonna happen eventually
where they're gonna start feeling like
an actual unit an actual team and i
thought it was such a great linchpin
moment of it's when economos deals the
final strike that's like the thing that
was really preventing this group from
feeling like an actual group was this
rift that was still occurring with you
know peacemaker and economist and then
when economos kills the gorilla and how
it's like just so celebratory and then
suddenly when they're in the like you
have this really good visual
illustration of when they're driving to
there
they are not getting along still and
then when they're driving back from
there covered in blood doing the mission
together they feel like a an actual team
an actual unit the camaraderie and i
love like the human touches of like
hardcore starts a group text you see
these people all struggle with
vulnerability and connecting i mean i
feel like
adebayo has things that she has to work
towards
but at the same time she has to work
towards but she's easily the most like
you know empathetic
sort of down to earth and in tune with
just being a human out of everybody yeah
so i i just love the character
development that they did here and like
it was it was one and one thing in terms
of action that was refreshing to finally
get in this show is something i've been
craving is i you know like the the scene
in the suicide squad that was so cool
especially upon peacemaker's
introduction in the suicide squad was
the butting of heads of like who's a
better shot who's a better marksman and
we haven't gotten that with this show
like we weren't getting any of that
and we finally got it we finally got it
in here and i thought it was just such a
really cool like pulpy
bloody action scene that we had where
they treated the butterfly i thought the
butterflies were a little bit more
intelligent to be honest
yeah the way they at least set them up
to be it seems like they're selectively
intelligent based on how important the
person they're embodying is
yeah but it seems like when they have to
fight they go like full on just primal
yeah like zombies swarm yeah it did seem
reminiscent of like the way zack snyder
realized that zombies an army of the
dead that was the thing i flashed you
the most yeah just bodies on top of
bodies throwing themselves at the
obstacle at hand yeah like i mean
coaches that's not the only time that
that's ever like jackson didn't invent
that
that type of style uh but that's the
thing my mind went to and obviously i'm
not gonna i'm not going to jump to the
conclusion that james gunn and company
arrived on that from like hey we saw
army of the dead but we're also filming
this simultaneously you know put it in
there put it in there yeah i'm not gonna
say that's the inspiration but yeah just
a little fun little thing i noticed i
thought they were setting up gorilla
grodd because i'm like talking gorilla
it must be and no it's not i
this girl like rod has like more than
just he he's a gorilla who could talk
she's massive and
has um oh god is it like some type of
i'm trying to recall right now as a
telepathic
yeah
telepathic ability telepathic is when
you can like communicate you know extra
sensory yes not like telekinesis is when
you can move stuff and telepathy is when
you can communicate with your mind no no
no yeah yeah
i don't know i'm trying to remember i've
played remember from injustice in the
flash show it's where my it's only like
a couple of comics he was never girl
across never really been my favorite
character but it was still exciting
i'd be excited to see
what a james gunn version of gorilla
grodd would be basically is that's why i
was jumping at that because he's never
really been someone i've personally
loved uh so the the idea of seeing him
in like a james gunn show like ooh
that's cool like he's kite man
[Laughter]
i wonder if he was going to watch his
harley quinn cartoon i wouldn't see his
fighters he seems like he's very well
steeped in all this stuff and probably
yeah keeps an eye on it regardless of
what he's working on it being for where
he seems like a fan of this stuff so i
could absolutely see that oh the
developing relationships is something
i'm really loving like what'd you think
about like when adebayo showed uh went
back to his place oh i thought that was
lovely and i mean you know like
yeah part of the charm of any of these
kinds of shows is getting to see the
different pairings of characters but
yeah like i thought that was played
really beautifully at first her being
like are you trying to hit on me and
then bringing it back to the central
conflict of the whole i mean she is a
great cipher because i mean yeah she's
clearly capable of these things that are
way over and beyond you know a regular
person's uh just you know normal you
know work array but at the same time it
pulls it into that you know real
conflict of great i have to do this
really nasty thing that i had forgotten
about with the diary you know they're
good at making you forget in those
moments of camaraderie and so yeah i i
thought it was a really sweet moment and
and a really well played moment on her
part just the conflict of having this
guy who is like finally opening up and
finally starting to you know at least
from him to her you know i trust you i
want to you know celebrate with you i
want to continue this bonding moment
with you and that drives the knife in
just that much deeper and it's like you
know she's not even the hardest
character to imagine that he could get
on board with because throughout the
show she's given him the biggest benefit
of the doubt out of everybody and it
hurts yeah just that much more the way
that that has to go down and two i mean
the way that she's sort of caught in
between
her mom who obviously is who she is and
has the status that she has and mern who
is a similar
kind of character in that you know he's
clearly pulling the strings of this
clandestine operation he's clearly
connected beyond anything that we're
aware of
and it's funny that it should come down
to her kind of in the middle of all
those things as like the unlikely
linchpin
and so yeah i i thought that was a a
beautiful but very kind of
heart-crunching exchange there and i i'm
very fascinated to see what will happen
when chris finally discovers the diary
yeah you know it is interesting how they
peel back chris because
you s you introduce him reintroduce him
back into the show with the kind of
humor that he has the kind of
personality he has when he's around
others and doing the missions and
whatever
and then over the course of a couple of
episodes later you really start showing
the layers underneath him that he's
really a lost soul feels like a lost
cause
and it's just really depressed
seeks validation like like you you
explore first with humor then you really
explore it with like the pathos of it
where it's just really raw and then when
he goes back into the work field
you see him resort back to that
personality
and now it's like oh
there's just so much more layers now to
who he is yeah
like he's doing the things he did in the
first couple episodes but now it's just
so much deeper when you're watching
you're like oh man he's just acting out
this whole time yeah it's a great
understanding of everything it's amazing
it's amazing writing i think i think
it's like great writing of the
characters yeah absolutely and uh yeah
like vigilante being part of the team a
little bit more but then of course you
got this other plot that i'm wondering
if it's mainly just going to be a setup
for
another c i feel like they're gearing up
for another season because we're almost
done with the
this
show and then hbo max does say season
one on it yeah so i don't know i haven't
heard anything about it being picked up
for another season must might be
something i just missed um it's doing
well enough right now that i could
definitely see it happening oh totally
100 uh but i'm like how would you wrap
up all this stuff with uh the the
the white dragon yeah yeah how would you
wrap all that stuff up here cause it
feels like it has to
a mount or build to something like
really catastrophic something big and
i'm like but if we got this whole other
thing that seems like way more important
to deal with yeah they're just keeping
them in jail so i i'm like is it i don't
want it to
end in some type of season one finale
where you're like too much too much now
you're doing too much you're trying to
wrap up too much you know yeah because
they have an interesting plot here
because like the butterfly thing is so
big and global scale threat
and uh obviously there's more
manipulation at play because there's
like all right economos is figuring out
what do we know when i'm like well if
mern really just had the agenda of
wanting to solely just take them out
like take them down
uh wouldn't he like
[ __ ] his way into giving them all
the information
like we got this information somehow you
know instead of just waiting for the
team to figure it out i'm wondering if
there's like some type of
war within the butterflies themselves
maybe yeah maybe he's trying to use the
humanity on his side or as his weapons
or something like that maybe yeah
because yeah why would he need to be
doing this if it was just about an
invasion or wiping out humanity it
doesn't seem like this would be
necessary yeah and if he's just like
you know like you're trying to like
figure out what his motive is if him
being a butterfly if he's a
um if he's a butterfly who's like i'm
against the butterfly cause and the
movement of what they're doing
so why wait for your team to like figure
this out for you for them when i'm like
should you like kind of you know plan
some information to make it easier for
them to figure this out yeah they're
more actively misleading or more
actively help
yes and with any attacks out of so i
don't know i mean that's something it's
a good mystery to build up and
but yeah i mean the whole thing with the
white dragon in there and then his dad
being in prison augie you know you got
then you got the cops um
who
i i want to kind of get to know them
better as characters because they do
seem like very generic cops and like as
much as there's jokes about like she's
asian yeah it's kind of what i just feel
like her character i like i have to
remember her name is sophie it's hard
for me to remember that yeah and it's uh
and i'm like but in my mind i'm like
you're just asian cop character yeah
well yeah because so much good though i
don't want to get that wrong
i'm sorry
i wanted they're they're doing good it's
just i i want to they're doing such a
good job at making everyone real
characters and i want to get to that
point with them yeah 100 i like them i
was thinking a similar thing i was like
i really like these actors i like
following these characters and yet
because they're not like there are
episodes that they don't even really
appear in up until this point and so it
does
i think
that's the most logical thing i can see
from here is okay maybe their story is
going to you know set up
a tension in the now of oh are they
going to find out that it really was
chris or is it going to mess up the
whole you know operation you know the
peacemaker is on but beyond that
yeah is this setting up for a greater
conflict with augie and i i
i don't know i mean like i i really like
yeah i really like the two of them and i
would like to have a better idea of
where they sit in the grand scheme of
things because if they are just some
kind of setup for augie to become the
true big bad next season or whatever uh
you know i feel like that might almost
feel a little inconsequential for two
characters who do feel like they're
supposed to be a bit more engaged and
important to the overall show or who
might ultimately wind up with our
unlikely team by the end or something so
yeah that's the one thread that like i
like each time and i don't quite know
where it's
headed for those particular characters i
mean
i don't know where it's going for the
cops it feels like for auggie they might
not need to do some big nazi white
dragon thing even though they've really
been teasing that i imagine that what
they what the focus would be is it would
be about chris's arc with confronting
his dad yeah and standing up to him and
really telling him you know
how his dad ruined him or
how he
doesn't believe in a lot of things his
dad believes in or you know some type of
way of standing up to him to show his
growth instead of always trying to get
his validation trying to get his
approval
because even while he he just strives
for that so much
you can call him a [ __ ] for ratting him
out yeah yeah well i mean he he's under
the impression that his
auggie's under the impression that his
son's trying to kill him yeah based off
of the events of last episode with
vigilante which i don't know if he knows
about i don't think chris knows about
that yeah yeah i don't think i don't
think he learned about that fact yet
yeah so yeah there's a lot to unpack and
um also shout i forget the james gunn's
girlfriend uh i forget the actors his
name um uh my bad parkour yeah but the
character harcourt yeah i love the
subtlety they do with her of just like
you see her growth and her warming up
through expressions not so much through
dialogue like everyone else kind of gets
dialogue
but you see a little looks yeah she gets
the look but i believe it you know it's
it's really believable so
and she's i i think she's one of the
she's a really interesting character i
think all the characters here pretty
much the main squad are really
interesting yeah
all right guys well here we are episode
five uh show is just incredibly
incredibly solid it is a very solid show
uh leave your thoughts down below thanks
so much for being here and uh let's
shout out some patrons who have been
showing their support at a higher tier
jason freemason dolan i crava eva
drazdakova pacemaker chase
gardner natalie doran always floor
floorin me you floor me melanie
committing felonies leblanc jen quite
the hen smith philip j smith jr the late
bloomer i'm falling for colin parker
posey rosie baby ghost busting justin
martin sj94 the most beautiful [ __ ]
rogue cree gotta go pee joanna saint
louis gotta go pee pee pee peter pacheco
simply faded p
lauren i gotta pee like an american
horse
shawn dawn using that long john to pee
levitt o'dell oh hell he's peeing on me
not peeing cause caz pattin is shattered
[Laughter]
differently sane gotta drain the main
veins still pee olivia del guy
i'm out of urine jokes
anonymous pseudonymous entity
yeah we did it we brought it around all
right guys thank you so much for
pledging to this uh
whatever this tier is
for p jokes about jokes that's where you
pledge that's what it said sign up to
get p jokes
next month it'll be a different bodily
function which one who knows thank you
for your support guys you guys are
thebomb.com we'll see you soon
[Music]